in my previous video i connected the
dots on several
truly remarkable similarities between
plato's description of the lost city of
atlantis
to that of the mysterious recot
structure also known as the eye of the
sahara
which is located in a remote region of
the western sahara desert in mauritania
and in this video which is essentially
part two i'm going to share many other
specific details that plato had shared
about atlantis
its empire that you will not only find
fascinating
but will also further support that the
recoc structure is indeed
the most likely location for the lost
city of atlantis
because let's not forget the remarkable
similarities which i outlined in my
previous video
including that atlantis was said to be
made of concentric circles
specifically three rings of water and
two of land
which matches the recot's design if it
had water in it
but even more significant than that it
precisely matches the diameter of what
would be the outer wall
when converting to modern measurements
this is an
unbelievably significant detail and when
you combine other similarities
including that the recod structure has
mountains to the north
with rivers on those mountains just as
plato described
and that atlantis was said to open to
the sea at the south which also matches
the topography of the recot structure
that is if it had at one point met the
coast of the ocean
which yes there is definitive evidence
that it did as i'll be sharing in just a
moment
but furthermore the entire area
surrounding the recot structure is a
massive level plane
with even a portion of it having a
rectangular resemblance
similar to what plato had described now
these are not the only similarities that
match plato's and solon's description of
the lost city of atlantis
and i shared those other details in my
prior video however there are a few
counter-arguments that would suggest
that the eye of the sahara
cannot be the true location of atlantis
for example many people still believe
that atlantis was just a myth
that plato made it up and it never
actually existed but
let's not forget that that's what people
said about the lost city of troy
even the so-called experts said that it
was made-up poetry
but that was until it was discovered in
turkey in the 1800s
proven to be true all along and they
said the same exact thing about the lost
city of angor
they said that it's just a myth and
never really existed but again
that was until they found it in the
dense jungle of cambodia
hidden for centuries until it was
rediscovered in the mid-1800s
now the most common response i received
in my prior video regarding the recot
structure being a possible location of
atlantis
were comments that said something to the
effect of the recot
is a natural formation so no it cannot
be atlantis
but why would the recon structure be a
natural formation
excluded from being atlantis if anything
being a natural formation would further
support
the possibility that it is atlantis
especially when you consider the
description of its massive size
do the math on the circumferences of
what would be the three
circles of water just how many miles or
kilometers of digging slash dredging
would be required to do this
the amount of earth that they would have
to move is mind-boggling and
unrealistic especially without having
heavy earth-moving machinery and
equipment to do so
i mean are we to think that the entire
massive design of atlantis
would have been a man-made construction
it would make far more sense for
atlantis to have been built upon a
natural formation
just as civilizations have been doing
for thousands of years
throughout the world and as we are still
doing today in many different places
but the most significant argument
against the recot structure being a
possible location of atlantis
involves it being hundreds of miles from
the ocean and having an elevation of
closer to 1300 feet above
sea level how could the recock be the
location of the capital of atlantis
when it was said to have been an island
many people have stated that it is
simply not
possible and that there is no evidence
to support that the recon
had met the ocean however we must
consider
one key piece of evidence which is that
all water wells within
and in the area around the recot
structure contain
exclusively salt water all the way down
to 200 meters below the surface
in fact only wells that have been
drilled to depths exceeding that 200
meters
in this region contain fresh water and
this is despite again being 500
kilometers inland from the coast
and being nearly 1300 feet above sea
level
how did that salt water get there but
perhaps just as significant
the center island is the one place
throughout the recot that
produces fresh spring water at surface
level
just as plato described the significance
of these details cannot be overstated
to take this a step further we must
consider the scientific explanation for
how the recot structure was formed
which was that it is a result of magma
chambers uplifting molten rock towards
the surface
in other words this area once had a
lower elevation than it does now
so is it possible that this area was at
sea level some 12 000 years ago
because according to plato atlantis
disappeared 11
600 years ago which like i mentioned in
my prior video
just so happens to coincide perfectly
with the younger driest climate
catastrophe
which had roughly ended approximately 11
600 years ago
and was followed by what is referred to
as meltwater pulse 1b
a sudden and rapid increase in global
sea levels
this similarity of 11 600 years ago is
another amazing
coincidence that furthers my thoughts
that the destruction of atlantis is
related to the younger driest event
but some will say that the recot could
not have increased to its current
elevation of nearly 1300 feet in just 12
000 years
so we must evaluate empirical scientific
data to understand what could be
geologically possible over the course of
some 12 000 years
let's consider the example of antarctica
that i used in my prior video and the
fact that the continent is rising at a
rate of 1.6 inches per year
as a result of subsurface activity 1.6
inches a year well do the math on the
recots elevation and you will see that
even if it was uplifted at a slower rate
than antarctica
it is well within the possibility over
this length of time
and here you can see just a few
different examples of several
outstanding comments i received from
viewers
who pointed this out and shared their
own calculations
now using those calculations take a look
at what the area would look like when
you account for the difference in
elevation
and sea level these images you are
seeing are from flood map.net
go there and play with the numbers and
tell me that this isn't incredibly
interesting and it certainly shows us
how this
area could have been an island with a
large plane just as plato described
and it could also provide an explanation
as to its location from the strait of
gibraltar
as no trace of atlantis has ever been
found in the atlantic ocean
despite countless searches over the last
several decades
plato also stated that the whole island
of atlantis was said to be towering
and steep towards the side of the sea
could this be possible at the recot
because look at the oddraw highlands
located near the recot
this long rim is 1500 feet higher
than the basin below and when you view
it with the use of flood maps
it's an additional similarity that may
match plato's description
now some will look at these flood maps
and say well yeah you're just playing
with numbers here to make the scenario
work
but we're really not because the known
scientific evidence
is that the recon structure was uplifted
by subsurface magma chambers
thus increasing the surrounding
elevation and we have empirical
scientific data that proves
that even if the recon was uplifted at a
much slower rate of what we already know
is possible
such as with the example of antarctica
it is well within the possibility
and not to mention there is additional
evidence of widespread subsurface
volcanic activity in the region
as we can see in the examples of the
nearby canary and cape verde islands
which are just off the coast of west
africa so clearly
the subsurface activity is widespread
and has been ongoing for a considerable
length of time
and the very fact that scientists have
so many unanswered questions about the
nature of the recot structure
it would be foolish to rule out the
various possibilities of what could have
happened there over the past 12 000
years
scientists specifically state that the
structure went through multiple stages
of being pushed up and down
to create the incredibly unique design
that we see today
pair that with what plato stated about
atlantis having sank into the ocean
perhaps the record was later pushed back
up out of the ocean
now another detail that is worth
repeating is that plato specifically
stated that there were an abundance of
elephants on the island
well elephants exist in mauritania today
and there's even ancient wall art
depicting them in caves near the recot
structure along with skeletal remains
this detail is small yet significant as
some of the other suggested locations
for atlantis
are in regions of which elephants are
not known to ever have existed
now these details i just shared are
certainly compelling but
where are the artifacts where's the
evidence that the civilization was ever
even there
well there actually are a ton of
artifacts that have been found in and
around the recon structure
and archaeologists do not know what
civilization they are from
and this was shared in the documentary
visiting atlantis which i mentioned in
my prior video
as being one of my sources of
information and i highly recommend that
you visit their website
visitingatlantis.com and follow the link
to watch their video i imagine that this
will help the creators of that
documentary but
in their video they show footage of many
different artifacts that have been found
in and around the recot including gold
jewelry
arrowheads even stone weights that
resemble ones that are commonly used
with fishing nets
they even found hundreds of stone
spheres cut with
unbelievable precision all of these
artifacts were found
in and around the recot at surface level
which
again is in the middle of nowhere
proving that at some point in the
distant past people did live there
the artifacts may not necessarily be as
old as atlantis but then again
we do not know who they belong to or
from when
but what about remnants of stone
structures and buildings
why haven't they found any of that well
unfortunately nobody has actually gone
looking
no heavy equipment has ever been brought
to the recot for excavation
nor has there ever been an
archaeological dig and for all we know
tons of evidence is buried just meters
below the surface which
let's not forget is a massive area
spanning nearly
15 miles across however it seems to me
that when you consider the surrounding
area
it is apparent that it was blasted by a
force of flowing water
the recon itself has been acknowledged
to be heavily eroded which we can all
see for ourselves
in my prior video i suggested that
perhaps a tsunami blasted this area
going from
west to east from the atlantic ocean
however
i now think that is just as likely that
this area was blasted by flowing water
going from east to west from the sahara
possibly originating from the
mediterranean sea as the topography upon
a closer look
could possibly support this or perhaps
more likely
the force of water could have come from
ancient lakes that are now known to have
existed in the sahara
for example the scientific evidence is
that the sahara desert
was once lush green and contained a
network of rivers and massive lakes
one of which would be one of the largest
in the world today if it still existed
as it covered more than 42
000 square miles or nearly 109 000
square kilometers of
surface area even look at this
fascinating article from just a couple
years ago where they discussed the
existence of a massive 500 kilometer
river that ran through north africa
specifically through the country of
mauritania
something that many people are not aware
of is just how recently the climate of
the sahara changed with
some of the most recent evidence
indicating that it suddenly went from
lush green
and covered with lakes and rivers to a
barren desert
get this just 5 000 years ago with
scientists calling it
one of the earth's most dramatic climate
shifts so
perhaps the recon was blasted by what
some have referred to as
the draining of the sahara but getting
back to the question of where are the
remains of stone buildings and
structures well to answer that question
we have to understand from which
direction the flowing water came from
and how strong it was
what we need are experts to evaluate the
geography of the area and determine the
likely places that we would find debris
that would be carried or pushed during
such a cataclysmic flood event
we should also consider the possibility
that this area was blasted from both
west to east
and from east to west during two
different events
and we must understand that most of any
remaining structural debris could
possibly be hundreds of kilometers away
from the recot
we just don't know how strong the force
was that came through here
but considering the evidence is so
apparent even when viewed from outer
space
and after so many thousands of years i
would suggest that it was stronger than
anything we ever thought possible
and it seems to me that not only would
the city have been completely
obliterated and carried or pushed away
but the layers of ground underneath the
city would have been taken with it along
with the buildings the walls the roads
and everything else included i mean just
think about how small
localized floods completely remove
modern roads
and the earth that lies underneath them
perhaps a massive flood could explain
the significant erosion of the recot
and considering that whatever the event
was that destroyed atlantis it was said
to happen in just one day and night
it was not a slow or gradual event it
was essentially apocalyptic
we must wrap our minds around just how
long of a period of time twelve thousand
years
is how many changes of seasons weather
climate
countless days of storms rain and wind
erosion to add with it
the recon we see today is certainly
different than what it looked like some
000 years ago and it's truly amazing
that this site has been completely
ignored
and it's even more fascinating that so
many people have never even heard of it
i even had comments on my prior video
from people from south africa saying
that they had never even heard of this
place before
but unfortunately it does not seem
likely that an excavation of this site
will happen anytime
soon take a look at the u.s department
of state's travel advisory for
mauritania
press pause to read the specifics but
yeah
that is very unfortunate to say the
least definitely leave a comment and
share what your thoughts are so far in
all of this but
now we'll jump into the specifics of the
city of atlantis and its empire
like i've stated the city of atlantis or
the capital was said to be made up of
concentric circles
three rings of water and two of land
let's start by discussing the center
island which was said to house the king
and royal family
along with their servants and most loyal
bodyguards
it was sparsely populated in relation to
its actual size and by the way
these images are artist renditions that
people have made which although they are
very well done
keep in mind they do not reflect the
scale in comparison to the size
of the actual rings of water and land
and these images also do not account for
the elevated nature of the land rings
including the center island which was
essentially a hill
but that said the center island was the
location of the main temple of poseidon
and one can only imagine what that
looked like the center island also had
the fabled garden of poseidon which
included exotic trees and fruit and it
had fountains and pools
this area was reserved for the royal
elite and high priests only the citizens
of atlantis did not have access to this
island
which was also said to be protected by
mighty walls and of course the ring of
water surrounding it
now the second land ring housed the
military which
was massive and said to consist of a
powerful navy
and the second ring of water was the
military harbor that was said to dock
at least get this 1 200
warships by the way could those stone
spheres i mentioned earlier have been
cannonballs
but 1200 warships incredible and it is
estimated that within the second land
ring
it housed upwards of 240
000 sailors this second ring of water
also housed the naval stalls and
supplies
it had underground docks soldier
training facilities
towers and guard houses this land ring
was essentially the military center of
the island
it also had a large road that was some
200 meters wide that ran
through the middle of the island
encircling the entire ring
this road was also used for horse races
think about the massive races that would
circuit the island it must have been a
sight to see
and attracted many people from afar
which
it must also be mentioned that many
different languages were said to be
spoken at atlantis
further indicating widespread trade and
visitation
it seems to me that this place was an
absolute fortress
it was protected as an island in the
first place and then contained
additional islands protected by rings of
water within it
how can an invading force ever overtake
this place
and if there was ever an uprising of the
people
how would they even be able to get to
and sack the innermost island where the
leaders were having been protected by
water and large walls and not to mention
the entire military in between you would
literally need an
air force or advanced artillery or
something
now the first land ring within the
island was the religious sector of the
city
and was said to be home to a large
priesthood it also had towers and gates
and even had hanging gardens as well its
water ring was a harbor for merchant
ships and it also functioned
as a public transport system small boats
would ferry people from one side of the
island to the other
and don't forget how large atlantis was
said to be so this transport system
would definitely be beyond useful
on the other side of the wall would be
what we would describe as downtown
atlantis
here is a quote from plato the area
between the outer wall and the merchant
harbor was densely crowded
and busy all day and all night it has
been estimated that the city of atlantis
may have been home
to over 1 million people which is not
hard to believe
based on its size and keep in mind that
this is half the size of new york city
and
we're not talking about manhattan we're
talking about the entire city
so considering that atlantis was said to
be busy
all day and all night and said to be
rich in architecture
bustling with trade and protected by a
great army and the fact that it
connected to the ocean
well this place was happening but it is
easy to understand how the description
of atlantis may have sounded crazy to
people 2500 years ago when plato first
shared the story
and this brings me back to a quote from
plato which is this tale about atlantis
though strange is certainly true having
been attested by solon who was the
wisest of the seven sages
and here we are thousands of years later
with all of our modern developments
we can certainly wrap our minds around a
city that would have been busy all day
and all night
bustling with trade and impressive
architecture but that aside atlantis
wasn't just a city
it was an empire consisting of ten
kingdoms which were said to be ruled by
the ten children of poseidon
who were born as five sets of twins it
was said to be a vast empire stretching
as far away as italy and even egypt was
a colony of atlantis
you'll recall me mentioning in my prior
video that the entire legend of atlantis
actually originates from the ancient
egyptians
the fact that egypt was said to be a
colony of atlantis could further the
support that the recot
is the location when you consider that
they are both on the same continent
at least when compared to other
suggested locations of atlantis which
are much further away
and by the way something interesting and
fun to share since so many people left
comments about it in the prior video
but isn't it amazing at just how much
the recon looks like an eye
many people made the comparison to the
notable eye of horus
seen throughout ancient egypt and i'm
not suggesting that there's a connection
here but it certainly is a unique
similarity
and i mean the re-cut even has a bluish
appearance to it when viewed from space
but that aside the fact that an
incredible civilization such as atlantis
was said to span such a vast distance
and consists of 10 kingdoms we really
need to reevaluate the age of various
megalithic structures found across the
region which we still cannot explain
today
including the pyramids of giza as just
one example
we really need to get into the mindset
that so many of the unanswered questions
and mysteries we have about
our ancient past is related to the fact
that we were far older than we ever
realized and that civilization whatever
it was or whoever they were
were wiped out a very long time ago and
all of this has been building upon the
videos i've been making since the
beginning of this channel which is that
what we were taught in school about our
true ancient past is far from it and
that we were far
older and advanced than we ever thought
so the question becomes
how old were we and how advanced did we
become but the issue goes beyond what
they're teaching or not teaching in
school
because you would only really become
aware of this information if you go
looking for it
you won't find it reported in the media
and the structure that runs most of the
scientific and academic community
shuns this information if you've
followed my channel for a while you've
heard me make many statements about the
so-called mainstream
and the topic of human civilization
dating back further
than 6 000 years ago with the sumerians
is something that they just do not want
to talk about and i've of course
made this example how they've ignored
the most recent scientific data
and one great example is the great
sphinx's water erosion around its
enclosure
and in my prior video though i gave the
example of the omissions in both the
atlantis and recot structure wikipedia
pages
well i encourage you to go there and
visit the view history tab on the recon
structure page
and look at everything that's taken
place since i uploaded my prior video on
september 4th
dozens of edits and dozens of deletions
by moderators
it was eventually locked and although
things do need to be cited properly
you will still not find one single word
that connects either of these two topics
together
and whether you like wikipedia or not we
have to acknowledge that wiki is what
shows up at the top of google searches
and is thus a primary source of
information to the masses
and regardless of whether the eye of the
sahara is the true location of atlantis
or not
it is certainly premature and honestly a
bit foolish
for anyone to rule it out and declare
that it could not have been the location
of atlantis
because make no mistake this site
matches far more aspects about the
description of atlantis
than any other proposed site from around
the world including the most specific
and precise
details this site the recall structure
needs to be studied and excavated
not disregarded and omitted and for some
reason
almost nobody has ever even heard of it
weird right
well i'll close it up there but i look
forward to reading the comments and
seeing what people's thoughts are on all
of this but
hit the like button subscribe i'm jimmy
this is bright insight and i have many
more videos to come on a whole wide
variety of topics
take care everybody